[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه
والاحزاب للانتخابات
باعت راسي موسكو اوكرانيا استهدفت قواعد
جويه روسيه بالمسيرات
وواشنطن عدلت منظومه مارس لتقصير مداح
الاخلاق
المتاجر مغلقه
تتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
[تصفيق]
افعال ترامب تزيد رصيدك تاكلا غضب جمهوري
من لقائه منكري الهولوكاست ودعوته لتعليق
الدستوره
[موسيقى]
فرادى ومجتمعه رحبت الكثير من الدول
بتوقيع الاطراف السودانيه على الاتفاق
الايطالي الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
والامارات وبريطانيا والنرويج قالت في
بيان المشترك صدر عن الخارجيه الامريكيه
انها خطوه الاولى اساسيه نحو تشكيل حكومه
بقياده مدنيين وتحديد ترتيبات الدستوريه
لتوجيه السودان خلال فتره الانتقاليه تفضي
الى انتخابات واشهد البيان بالجهود
المبذوله للحصول على دعم مجموعه واسعه من
الجهاد السودانيه لهذا الاتفاق الايطالي
ودعوتهم الى حوار مستمر وشامل وحط كل
الاطراف على الانقراض في هذا الحوار بشكل
عاجل وبحسن
نيه مشيره الى ان الجيش قال بوضوح انه
مستعد للانسحاب من السياسه وهو ما اكده
عبد الفتاح البرهان في لقاء خاص بالعربيه
مشددا على ان الاتفاق الايطالي لم يتجاوز
احد
لم يتجاوز احد حتى الان وهو مفتوح ومطروح
للجميع للحاق به اللحاق به ليس كاد تبع
ولكن للحاق به كمكون اساسي يشارك في نقاش
ماطور فيه من قضايا نحن نسعى لحدوث توافق
اذا كان داخل القوى السياسيه او داخل
القوى السياسيه والعسكريه همم سنزعه لكمال
هذا التوافق بين هذه المجموعات ونزع
الاستكمال توقيع القوه التي نرى انها
ضروريه ان تكون موجوده في ساحه السياسيه
اذا انظار السودانيين توجهت اليوم للقصر
الرئاسي لمتابعه الاتفاق بين الشرق
العسكري في مجلس السياده الحاكم وقوى
اعلان الحريه والتغيير الاتفاق يهدفوا
لانهاء الازمه السياسيه في السودان واعاده
البلاد الى الحكم المدني وسط حضور دوليا
واقليم كبير
بحسب الصوره الواسعه يتكون الاتفاق من
المبادئ العامه التي تشمل ترسيخ مبدا
العداله والمحاسبه واليه العداله
الانتقاليه ووضع حد للافلات من العقاب
ايضا اكد الاتفاق على ان يكون الجيش مهنيا
واحدا و ملتزما بالعقيده العسكريه فضلا عن
اقامه سلطه مدنيه بالكامل دون مشاركه
القوات النظاميه في التفاصيل اقر الاتفاق
الايطالي ان تكون مده المرحله الانتقاليه
عامين تبدا اعتبارا من لحظه تعيين رئيس
الوزراء على تم اختياره من القوى الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي اعطى الاتفاق رئيس
الوزراء صلاحيات اوسع خلال المرحله
الانتقاليه منها انه سيكون رئيس مجلس
الامن والدفاع في الجانب السياسي سيتم
اطلاق عمليه شامله لصياغه الدستور ثم
تنظيم عمليه انتخابيه بنهايه فتره
انتقاليه مدتها 24 شهرا الحكومه ستعمل على
معالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه واصلاح الاجهزه
القانونيه بما يحقق استقلاليتها ومهنيتها
كذلك ستسعى الحكومه الانتقاليه الانتهاجي
سياسه خارجيه متوازنه تحقق مصالح السودان
اضافه لاستكمال السلام مع الحركات المسلحه
غير الموقعه على الارتفاع في الجانب
الامني والعسكري تلتزم القوات المسلحه
بعدم التحجب والتمسك بالنظام الدستوري
المدني ايضا على الجيش تنفيذ المهام
الوارده بدمج قوات التدخل السريع والحركات
المسلحه في الجيش وفق الترتيبات الامنيه
المتفق عليها وفقا لتفاقه جوبا
[موسيقى]
الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان شهد توقيع
عده قوى وحركات عليه بينما رفضته اخرى
لنتعرف على ابرز القوى من الجانبين
[موسيقى]
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه عبد الفتاح
البرهان اعلن ان الاتفاق الذي تم توقيعه
يعني الصراعي بين القوى المدنيه والعسكريه
وكاد ان الغايه الاهم هي تحويل الجيش الى
مؤسسه دستوريه ومنعو تاسيسه
ان الموافقه على هذا الاتفاق
لا تعني اتفاق مع طرف واحد او مع جهه
محدده
وانما هو توافق
وتراضي على قضايا وطنيه يجب ان يتم وضع
الحلول لها بمشاركه واسعه من القوه
المدنيه
واصحاب المصلحه بنيه الوصول لمخرجات تنهي
حاله الصراع والتشاكس القائم بين القوه
المدنيه
والقوه العسكريه حتى نمهد الطريق نحو
التحول الديمقراطي الحقيقي
كان من اللافت اليوم ان البرهان ردد شعار
العسكر للثكنات خلال خطاب اليوم هذه
العباره طالما استخدمها المحتجون للمطالبه
بخروج الجيش من المشهد السياسي
[موسيقى]
العسكريه من العمليه السياسيه نهائيا
هذا الامر
يجب ان يصاحبه خروج القوى السياسيه من
المشاركه في مرحله التقليه
استجابه لمطلب الثوار
العسكر للسكنات والاحزاب للانتخابات
الايطالي هو استعاده الحكم المدني
والعقد الاجتماعي الجديد
الساده والسيدات ان هذا الاتفاق الايطالي
عنوانه استعاده الحكم المدني الديموغرافي
واكمال مهام ثوره ديسمبر المجيده وغايته
توحيد بنات وابناء شعبنا تحت ظل مشروع
وطني غائم على الحريه والسلام والعداله
والمواطنه في اقامه سلطه مدنيه ديموقراطيه
تستكمل مهام الانتقال
المبعوث الاممي للسودان فولكربرتس اشاد
بالاتفاق بهذا الاتفاق الذي قال انه يلبي
تطلعات الشعب السوداني واعتبر ان العمليه
التي ادت الى هذا الاتفاق كانت مملوكه
للسودانيين وقياداتهم
[موسيقى]
الى حل للازمه السياسيه في البلاد كل ذلك
من اجل اعاده النظام الدستوري بما يتماشى
مع مطالب الشعب الهادفه لاصلاح المدني
وذهاب نحو اجراء الانتخابات وترسيخ قيم
الديمقراطيه هذا الالتزام نحو التحول
المدني بمثابه عمليه ادت الى هذا الاتفاق
كانت مملوكه للسودانيين وقيادتهم اننا
نعمل ان تترجم بنود الاتفاق لافعال بشكل
سريع واحترام الحقوق والحريات بغض النظر
عن خلفياتها السياسيه والعرقيه والدينيه
مع توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي انطلقت تظاهرا
من محطه مجدار في الخرطوم باتجاه القصر
الجمهوري ورفع المتظاهرون شعارات المناهضه
للاتفاق
وردت ورددت انباء عن اطلاق الشرطه الغاز
المسيء للدموع على المتظاهرين في محطه
شروني بالشارع القصر
حول هذا الاتفاق ينضم الينا من الخرطوم
علي بشير ساور عضو المكتب السياسي لحزب
الامه القومي والعضو في الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي ومن الخرطوم ايضا اللواء
الركن الدكتور محمد نعمه الله جبريل
الباحث العسكري اهلا بكما ضيفيه العزيزين
ابدا معك سيد همم
دائما ما كان هناك مخاوف من نوايا المكون
العسكري و بانه يريد ان يستاثر بالسلطه
وما يقوم به من خطوات ومناورات سياسيه ما
الذي سمعتموه اليوم
وقراتموه في هذا الاتفاق طب انا كمكم
تجاه هذا المكون العسكري
الكريم وعمرك اخي الشعب السوداني على هذا
الانجاز العظيم الذي تحقق اليوم بمجهود
كبير جدا من كل القوه السياسيه
والمكون العسكري والمجتمع الدولي وبالتالي
هذا الاتفاق حقيقه يلبي طموحات الشعب
السوداني
ويسس لفتره لدستور الفتره الانتقاليه وفي
همم اعاده كل القضايا العالقه
والترسيغ لحكومه الانتقاليه للامور
الانتخابات حره ونزيهه في السودان
وبالتالي هذا الاتفاق اليوم همم سوف يلبي
جميع طموحات الشعب السوداني ونسير فيهم
الى ان يحقق الاتجاه الذي هو يطلبه الشعب
السوداني ومطالب الشارع وبالتالي اليوم
احنا نطمئني على كل ما بزل من مجهود في
هذا الاتفاق لغايه سمعتم الكلمات التي قال
اغالها المتحدثين في هذا الاتفاق وبالتالي
همم المكون العسكري همم اكد ذلك انه هو
سوف يتخلى عن العمل السياسي وارجع الى
السكنات زي ما كما قاله القائد العام وكما
قاله الفريق اول همم
هنالك همم
علاقه سوف تحل في في في الايام القادمه في
همم
الفتره همم القريبه التي يتم فيها همم
تاسيس للدستور الانتقالي همم
دعنا نشرك اللواء محمد معنا في هذا النقاش
لاسالك لواء محمد همم حجه المكون
دائما ما كانت همم اننا نحن الضامن لامن
السودان في هذا الاتفاق ما حدود همم عمله
ما مساحته
لك
ولضيفك الكريم وللمستمعين والمشاهدين همم
انا حياه بفتكر انه اي كلام عن اتفاق في
هذا الوقت في السودان انا افتكر انه كلام
محمود وطيب وينبغي ان تدفع جميع القوى
تجاه هذا الاتفاق همم
بقراءه يعني واضحه لهذا الاتفاق همم دائما
ان احنا بنقول
الجواب من عنوانه
فالاتفاق بتحدث عن الاتفاق الاطار السياسي
الاتفاق الايطالي السياسي
وبالتالي انا بفتكر انه كل ما دار انا
الحقيقه انت بعدت كل الكلمات كل ما دار هو
يعني يصب في اتجاه استعاده السلطه
وخروج
المؤسسه العسكريه من السياسه
ولذلك بالقراءه هذا التوقيت كانت المؤسسه
العسكريه جزء متكامل وجزر فاعل
ومرتكز اتكى عليه جميع في انه فا في تناقض
هنا كيف انت تخرج المؤسسه العسكريه من
السياسه وتجيء توقع كان ينبغي ان يتم هذا
الاتفاق بعيد عن المؤسسه العسكريه
نعم انت اصلك يعني فاعل خروج المؤسسه
العسكريه من السياسه اذا لم تشارك
والمؤسسه العسكريه قالت
فلتذهب الاحزاب وتضع يعني اتفاق وتيجي نحن
مستعدين نافع ننفذ فكان ينبغي ان يتم هذا
الاتفاق في موقع مختلف اول حاجه عن مجلس
ال ال
هذه النقطه للسيد علي ما رايك هل كان هذا
الاتفاق يجب ان يتم بعيدا عن المؤسسه
العسكريه
هل كان ليكون مقبولا ان كان من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه ومن الخارج من الدول
الاجنبيه
العسكريه لان المصري العسكريه هي التي
قامت
بالانقلاب و25 اكتوبر وبالتالي هذه
المؤثره العسكريه هي التي كانت تحكي
السيطره على السلطه بالتالي كيف يتم
خارجها او تن بعيدا عنها لانها هي المسؤول
الاساسي في هذا الموضوع بالتالي تم الت-
ال- ال-
المفاوضات
العسكريه بواسطه الاليه او الرباعيه
والامم المتحده والمجتمع الدولي وبالتالي
همم ضروري جدا ان المعسل عسكريه تكون
موجوده عشان لذلك لانه هذا الامر هو يعني
تماما والمطالب شاعر المطالب بالشعر هي
تتحدث عن انه همم ارجاع القوات القوات
المسلحه الى الى الاسئله البعيد عن
السياسه وبالتالي ده ده ده مربط الفرس في
التاريخ كيف يتم هذا الاتفاق بعيد عن
المؤسسه العسكريه على فكره بهذه النقطه
سيد علي همم اود ان اسال عن قوى الحريه
والتغيير بالقادم من الايام
هل الاخرى التي لم توقع هلا هذه على هذا
الاتفاق همم هناك تظاهرات اليوم ايضا
بالسودان هل ستكون قادره على التوحد
لاختيار رئيس للوزراء وتاليف حكومه
اقول حريه الان هي موحده حقيقه هنالك في
ناس لها اراه ولها بعض التحفظات وبالتالي
الباب مفتوح للوصول الى الى التوقيع في
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي وان شاء الله ان نحن
ساعيين والقوه سياسيه همم
كل همم القوى السياسيه في السودان والرايه
السودان
لخروج من الازمات سودانيه التي ترتبت عليه
منذ زمن طويل في هذه الفتره وبالتالي همم
القوه السياسيه هو الحريه والتغيير
لها قلب مفتوح لحل القضيه السودانيه في
همم في جمع القوه السياسيه وكل الاطراف
للاشتراك في المسوده القادمه
سوف نخرج بمظهر قوي جدا ان شاء الله في في
العالم وانه القوه المدنيه هي التي لها
دور كبير جدا في حمايه الهمم الفتره
الانتقاليه وبالتالي نحن نطالب المجتمع
الدولي ونطالب المكون العسكري ونطالب
الاخوه الذين ممانعين عن التوقيت
سيد علي اعذرني على المقاطعه الى اللواء
محمد لاساله عن ضمانات يعني اتفاق اليوم
هو اتفاق عام اطار ما الضمانات لتنفيذه
ونجاحيه ما القطر
طيب طيب
افتكر هو كلام صحيح لكن لماذا العجله كان
ينبغي ان تتحد هذه القوه السياسيه
وتحضر متفقه لانه هذا الاتفاق لم ياتي
الجديد يعني مساله خروج القوات المسلحه من
همم المسرح السياسي يمكن مطروحه من فتره
طويله جدا من المكونه العسكري وطلب من
الاخوه في
القوه السياسيه انها تتفق وتصل والبرهان
اليوم في حديث قال كل ما حصل كان تشاكس
بين المدعيين العسكريين همم قال هذا تشاكس
كان تشاكس وكنا وكنا واخطاء كثيره جدا اذا
كان ينبغي لهذه القوه السياسيه انت تتفق
اولا لانه الش يعني والقوه السياسيه الان
هي بتفتكر انه ينبغي ان تخرج القوات
المسلحه والقوات المسلحه تقول تخرج اذا
التوقيع بتاع القوات المسلحه ما كان مطلوب
واحد ما هي الضمانات يعني اذا نحن مسكنا
الحريه والتغيير كطرف والمؤسسه العسكريه
كرفت ذيل عندهم تجربه مريره وصلوا لهم
مستوى عاده موسيقى
ونجن في النهايه نقول والله احنا عملنا ما
هو الجديد وما هي الضمانات
انا بفتكر هذا الاتفاق يعني اوضح يعني عدم
مقدره الاحزاب على اداره الشان السياسي
يعني بفتكر انه كان الفرصه برده بكرر كان
عندهم الفرصه الاحزاب لوحدها تتفق وتجدد
تجبر المؤسسه العسكريه على انها تخرج
الشين ثاني في تناقض كبير جدا بين الخطاب
والالقائه
ممثل لهذه القوه وبين خطاب البرهان المرير
عنده اهداف عنده غايات بيقول انه في
الفقره خمسه انا كتبت انه
بمجرد الاتفاق النهائي على هذا الاتفاق
تخرج المؤسسه العسكريه وتسلم السلطه الى
المدنيين وده طبعا موارد
يستطيعوا استلام السلطه من العسكريين الا
من خلال الانتخابات واحد اثنين الحديث عن
انه يعني اهداف
عريضه لا يمكن
التفاصيل
نعم نعم اعذرني على النقاطعه ولكن وقتنا
انتهى ربما بلقاءات اخرى نوضح هذه النقاط
من الخرطوم اذا لواء الركن دكتور محمد
نعمه الله جبريل وايضا همم السيد علي بشير
ساوير عضو المكتب السياسي لحزب الامه
القومي
[موسيقى]
تابعونا معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
روسيا تهونوا من اثر تحديد سعر لنصفها على
الحرب ومكروه يطرق باب التفاوض رغم غضب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعتراضها وسائل الدفاع الجوي عددا
من الطائرات المسيرات الاوكرانيه التي
اطلقها نظام اكياس ضد مطارين في مقاطعه
تاير يازان وسيراتوف الروسيتين قالت
الدفاع الروسيه ان نظام اكياف حاولت
توجيها ضربات باستخدام طائرات مسيره سوفيه
الصنع ضد المطريه
هو قرار لم يعجب الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي
ميرزلت حينما اتفق عليه وكذلك روسيا التي
لم تعره اي اهتمام لكنهم شاؤوا ام ابوا
فان الاتفاق على حظر النفط الروسي بالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا
دخل حيز التنفيذه مع فرد حد اقصى لسعر
البرميل الواحد على ان لا يتجاوز قدره
الستينات دولارا ولن يبقى عند هذا الحد بل
سيتغير كل شهرين اعتبارا من منتصفين يناير
وباجمع الاوروبي ومن المفترض ان يتم تحديد
السقف في كل مره عند مستوى اقل بنسبه 5%
من سعر السوق وفقا لبيانات وكاله الطاقه
الدوليه هذا الحظر الذي بدا سا ريانه ضمن
حزمه سادسه من العقوبات الاوروبيه المفروض
على واردات النفط الخام الروسي المنقوله
بحرا اما المنتجات مكرره المنقوله ايضا عن
طريق البحر فستبدا في فبراير العام القادم
وعن استثناءات هذا الحظر فحصلت عليه
بالغاليه التي ستستمر باستراد خام الاورال
الروسي حتى نهايه عام 2024
وتواصل مجموعه من الدول استيراد النفط من
روسيا على طول خط انابيب دروجبا او انبوب
الصداقه كما سمي منذ اكثر من نصف القرن
وتنطبق الاعفاءات على ثلاث دول اعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبيه الا وهي المجر سوفاكيا
اتشيكا ذلك الاعتمادها على خط انابيب
النفط من روسيا بسبب موقعها الجغرافي وعدم
قدرتها على استبدال الواردات بسرعه يضاف
اليها اعلان اليابان عن تطبيق الحد الاقصى
للنص الروسي ولكن باستثناء النفط الخام
المستوردي من مصنع خليل اثنين في اقصى شرق
روسيا كون شركات الطاقه اليابانيه تمتلك
حصاصه هناك اذا خفت انتقادات او خفت
الانتقاد الاوكراني لهذا القرار من باب ان
حضرا قليلا افضل من لا شيء لكن روسيا
وبنبره حازمه لن تقبل بالتسقيف الذي سيؤدي
الى حد او على حد تعبيرها الى زعزعه
استقرار اسواق الطاقه العالميه
[موسيقى]
من الاولاد
همم سكس
بي ليزر
وقالبا وضع سقفا لاسعار والكريم لن يتحدث
عن حزمه اجراءات للرد على خطوه الغرب
بالتاكيد وضعوا سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي
سيضر بالموازنه المحليه خاصه ان التقاريره
تتحدث عن انه موسكو تبيعه بعض من نفطها
بخصومات في الاسواق العالميه حجم مساهمه
النفط في الموازنه الروسيه يصل قرابه 40%
مقابله 12% من الغاز وصارت الماليه
الروسيه تحدثت عن ان ارادات النفط والغاز
الاضافيه لشهر نوفمبر الماضي جاءت بنحو 90
مليار روبل تقريبا دون المستوى المتوقع
قرار الحظر كما يبدو يهدف الى ردع روسيا
عن تمويل عملياتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا
سزامنا مع محاولات اخرى لحل الازمه وبدء
مفاوضات بين موسكو وكياف فبعد ان انهى
الرئيس الفرنسي
زيارته الى واشنطن للقاء نظيره الامريكي
جوبادل اعلنا معا عن رغبتهما في السعي
لتوسل الى انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا على
طاوله المفاوضات
بايدن الوحيد ان يكون الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتينج جدا بشان نهائي ما اسماء غزوان ثم
جاء رد موسكو سريعا بالرفض على لسان
المتحدث باسم الكريم
مع قوله ان بلاده ليست مستعده للدخول في
محادثات اذا كان شرط واشنطن ان تغادر
روسكو روسيا اوكرانيا لكن تصريح اخر
لمكرون في احد المقابلات التلفزيونيه اثار
حفيظه الاوكرانيين اذا لم نقل غضبه
قطعه من مسلسل
كما سمعتهم تحدث مكروه عن انه يجب تفهم
ودروسيا حول مخاوفها والضمانات الامنيه
لاجراء محادثات الفعاله على عكس اوكرانيا
وموقفها الصريح بان المفاوضات لن تبدا الا
بانسحاب القوات الروسيه عن اراضيها
اوليكسي دانيل مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني كان احد الرافدين بجراه لاقوال
مكروم واعتبر انها تنطلق من افواه لمنطق
غريب للدبلوماسيه كان قد ولزمنه وتسائل
كيف يريدون توفير ضمانات امنيه لدوله
ارهابيه وقاتله بل ويطلبون منا بدلا من
نورمبرج ان وقع اتفاقيه مع روسيا ونصافحها
يتساءل مضيفا ان الدماء الاوكرانيه على
ايدي بوتن غير مهمه كالعاده ويعارض
الكثيرون في اوكرانيا والغرب بشده اجراء
اي مفاوضات مع بوتن من شانها ان تكافئه
بتنازلات
حربين عمرها اقترب من اتمام عام باكمله
ويعتبر ما قاله مكروه يعتبر رد وصفه بعض
الاوكرانيين بالعاطفين مع حاجه موسكو الى
ضمانات امنيه وانه اخذ وقت طويل
ففي فبراير العام الماضي وشهد بوتن رساله
لنظره الفرنسي خلال احد المؤتمرات التي
جمعتهما افاد حينها بان روسيا ستواصل
محاوله الحصول على اجابات من الغرب على
مطالبها الامنيه الثلاثه الرئيسه والتي
تنص على الاقل مزيد من التوسع لحلف شمال
الاطلسي ولا انتشار الصواريخ بالقرب من
حدودها اضافه لتقليص البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه لحلف الاطلسي في اوروبا الى
مستويات عام 1997 لكن بالرغم من ذلك مكروم
لم ياتي باي خيط يشير الى ان فرنسا ستتوقف
عن دعم اوكرانيا رغم مساعه نحو مفاوضات
بين الطرفين
يدومك
الينا من باريس اهلا بك دكتور امل يعني
كلام مكرون لافتت يعني هو يتحدث عن ضروره
اعطاء او احترام امم ما تطلبه روسيا بانها
تريد ضمانات امنيه لماذا لم تعطى هذه
الضمانات لروسيا من البدايه اليس هذا ما
طلبه بوتن قبل اندلاع هذه الحرب وعليه ما
كانت لتندلع ولم نكن لنرى هذه
الارواح تهدر وهذا الجمال
تعلمين انا اليوم مساله الامن الاوروبي
ااا مساله مهمه جدا بالنسبه للاوروبيين
وليس الرئيس مكرون وحده بل ايضا المستشار
الالماني اولف شولز تحدث عن ضمان الامن
الاوروبي يعني اوروبا بدون حرب واوروبا
تعيش في السلم كان هذا الواقع بعد نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بالنسبه للضمانات يعني تعلمين انه في
الحرب همم الذي يتقدم على الارض ووافقه
تقدم المعارك الميدانيه همم يمكن التحدث
عن والتفاوض حول طاوله المفاوضات فيما بعد
يعني همم اليوم التقدم الروسي الحرب طويله
جدا باتت مكلفه للاوروبيين اليوم
الاوروبيون همم علموا فهموا يشهدون ان هذه
الحرب تنعكس تداعيتها عليهم ااه بشكل سلبي
جدا هناك ايضا التلويح
يعني همم استخدام السلاح النووي
الرئيس الروسي يلوح بين الاونه والاخرى
بامكانيه استخدام هذا السلاح حتى وان كانت
هذه الفرضيه بعيده همم بشكل كبير طبعا
الحرب النوويه اليوم هناك همم تحذير من
حرب بارده وتقسيم العالم ل همم مجموعات
كما حصل خلال حرب البارده اذا طول هذه
الحرب تداعيات هذه الحرب همم يعني استمرار
بوتين همم رغم كل
العقوبات التي همم قام بها والتي وضعها
همم كان الاتحاد الاوروبي او الغرب بشكل
عام يعني الواقع الميداني اليوم هو الذي
يفرض ايه شروط التفاوض شروط الضمانات التي
تقدم اليوم اوروبا تريد التفاوض اوروبا
اليوم تريد انهاء الحرب او تتمنى على
الاقل انهاء هذه الحرب اكيد هذا يزعج
الاوكرانيين لان الاكرانيين يريدون دعما
همم مستمر من من الغرب همم ولكن اليوم
يعني همم الشتاء على الابواب وبدا الشتاء
هناك ازمه كهرباء ربما ازمه غاز الى اخره
كل هذا يحدد همم طبيعه المرحله المقبله
والتضحيات التي يمكن ان يقدمها دكتور امل
يعني التحركات الدبلوماسيه وموضوع
المفاوضات لماكرون واتى مباشره بعد زيارته
همم التاريخيه هكذا وصفت الى واشنطن
ولقائه بايضا فعليا هل نفهم من هذا
التوقيت انا الامريكيين ربما اعظم لو
الاخضر لمكرون للبدء همم ايجاد ربما خيوط
لهكذا مفاوضات ولن يعلنوا ربما موقف
الرسميا منها لاحقا
يعني
اليوم الرئيس بيضا لا يريد التفاوض بشكل
مباشر لا يريد تفاوض الا بشروطه ولكن لابد
من مسح العصا في الوسط يعني اوروبا اليوم
كان رئيس الفرنسي يعني بشكل او باخر هو
يحمل الرساله الاوروبيه خلال هذه الزياره
الى واشنطن حقيقه استطاع انه ان يشكل همم
خرقا همم
بالنسبه
للموقف الامريكي وهمم اقناعه الرئيس
الرئيس اقناع الرئيس ميدا يعني
ضروره
الامور والتوسل الى حل ما لان اليوم همم
المتضرر الاكبر همم هو همم اوروبا طبعا
يعني الولايات المتحده بعيده جغرافيه عن
روسيا وعن اوكرانيا وبالتالي هذا الخلق
همم لا ادري ان كان تاريخيا ولكن الاكيد
هو انه خرق دبلوماسي حقيقي همم اقناع
الرئيس الامريكي بضروره الذهاب الى طاوله
المفاوضات
وبالتالي الذي يلعب هذا الدور دور الوسيط
او دور اا يعني ماسك العصب الوسط لانه
هناك طبعا كما ذكرت في البدايه مساله
العقوبات بالنسبه لتحديد سقف لسعر النفط
ومن جهه اخرى
لتقريب وجهات النظر النظر ولكن تبقى همم
العقده في الشروط الروسيه يعني هل روسيا
ستقبل بهم همم الوسيط الفرنسي او بالرئيس
الفرنسي كي يكون هذا اولا همم وثانيا همم
وفقه اي شروط يعني هل الشروط الاوروبيه
ستكون الانسحاب الكامل لروسيا من كل
الاراضي الاوكانيه ام همم الشروط هي كما
حصل في همم اتفاقيه مين يعني همم اا ايقاف
المعارك الان والتفاوض على المناطق
والاراضي التي تم سيطره عليها شكرا لك
الدكتوره امل نادر الكاتبه والباحثه
السياسيه
وفي تقرير يعكس ايضا رغبه امريكيه في
ابقاء الصراع عند حدود معينه نقلت وسترجون
عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان واشنطن عدلت سرا
قاذفات صواريخ مارس المتقدمه التي قدمتها
لاوكرانيا حتى لا يمكن استخدامها لاطلاق
صواريخ بعيده المدى على روسيا وبحسب
المسؤولين فان هذه الخطوه بمثابه اجراء
احترازيا ضروري للحد من مخاطر اندلاع حرب
اوسع مع موسكو ومنذ يونيو الماضي زودت
واشنطن كياف ب 20 قاضي فت صواريخ من هذا
الطراز ذي القدره العاليه على الحركه
وبخزون كبير من الصواريخ الموجهه بالاقمار
الصناعيه بمدى خمسين مللا تقريبا وسعدت
هذه الاسلحه اوكرانيه على ضرب مستودعات
الذخيره همم الروسيه والامدادات اللوجستيه
ومراكز القياده على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لكن التعديلات التي اجريت على المنظومه
تجعلها غير قادره على اطلاق الصواريخ التي
يبلغ مداها حوالي 200 مللي بعكس هذه
التعديلات المخاوف الامريكيه من توقف
الشريك الاوكرانيه عن الوفاء بوعده بعدم
استهداف الاراضي الروسيه باسلحه امريكيه
كما تعكس مخاوف واشنطن من حصولك يافا على
الصواريخ من مصادر اخرى واستخدام المنصات
الامريكيه لاطلاقها
[موسيقى]
افادت معلومات نقلتها قناه ايران
انترناشونال باغلاق محلات تجاريه ابوابها
في عده مدن ايرانيه في اطار اضراب عام من
الخامس الى السابع من ديسمبر وفي طهران
تظهر مقاطع الفيديو والمرسله الى ايران
انترناشونال انا الباعه في اسواق لازار
وازرق
اضربوا عن العمل وابقوا محالهم مغلقه وفقا
لمجلس تنسيق الاحتجاجات انضم عمال عقود
النفط في ايران للاضرابه اه يستمر طلاب
الجامعات في شتى المدن الايرانيه في
اضرابهم الذي بدا مع انطلاقه هذه
الاحتجاجات كما اعربت مجموعه من الفنانين
والرياضيين عن تضامنها مع الاضرابات
العامه واعلنت انها لن تمارس انشطه في هذه
الايام الثلاثه
الشرطه الاخلاق في ايران تم حلها في خطوه
فسرت على انها رضوخ من النظام للشارع
المحتج المدعي العام الايراني لم يقدم
تفاصيل حول مستقبل شرطه الاخلاق او ما اذا
كان حلها سيكون بجميع انحاء البلاد وبشكل
دائم ام لا ليبقى مستقبل هذه القوه غامضه
السؤال الذي يطرحه الايرانيون هو هل سيذبح
هل هذه القوه خطوات اخرى مشابهه فكره او
فكره بحث ملف شرطه الاخلاق متداوله منذ
الايام الاولى بعد مقتل مهسه امينه ليخرج
نواه في البرلمان ويعلن تشكيل لجنه الصحه
حقائق لتحديد سبب وفاه امين اضافه لما قد
يترتب على ذلك من تبعات على شرطه الاداب
الصحفيه والناشطه الايرانيه مسيح علي نجاد
اعتبرت ان الغاء شرطه الاخلاق مجرد بدايه
لان الايرانيه هو الايرانيين بداوا
الاعتراض على الحجاب الا وسيتبعه رفض
المنظومه الحاكمه كما يحدث في الشارع
والمطالبه بتغييرها
[موسيقى]
اذا فالمحتاجون باتوا ينادون بالاعتراف
بحريه الحجاب في ايران وليس الحجاب
الانساني فضلا عن طرح تساؤلات حول النظام
الحاكم او ما يطلق عليه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الرد جاء من الرئاسه قبل اسبوع
حين قال محمد دقان نائب الرئيس الايراني
للشؤون القانونيه في مؤتمر صحفي انه من
المستحيل الاستفتاء على اصل النظام الحاكم
وحريه ارتداء الحجاب لاحقان اضاف ان اي
استفتاء محتمل سيجري بموافقه المرشد
وتصميد ثلثين وبالبرلمان وانه من المستحيل
تغيير نظام الجمهوريه كما ان حريه الحجاب
تتعارض مع مبادئ ايران بحسب وصفه
تزامن عقد الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي اجتماعا
مغلقا مع رئيس البرلمان محمد باقر قالباف
ليخرج المتحدث باسم الرئاسه البرلمان
قائلا ان الجزء الاساسي من النقاش تركز
على الاحوال المعيشيه والاقتصاديه واضاف
ان افضل طريقه لتحقيق الاستقرار هي
الاهتمام بالمطالب الحقيقيه للشعب على حد
قوله بشكل عام يرى مراقبون ان وسائل
الاعلام الرسميه الايرانيه بدات تتبنى
لهجه اكثر تصالحيه معبره عن رغبه في
التعامل مع مشكلات الشعب الايراني
[موسيقى]
كرواتيا بين 8 الكبار في المونديال والفضل
لحارسها الامير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كعادته يحب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ان يحدث
الجلابه بتصريحاته وافعاله احداثها منشره
من الغاء جميع القواعد والوائح والمواد
مما في ذلك تلك الوارده في الدستور تصريح
البيت الابيض قبل ان يلقي بالترامب في
مرمى انتقادات السياسيين الامريكيين الذين
ذهبوا بعضهم لوصفي ما فعله كما يطلق النار
على قدميه البعض منهم اعتبر ان ترامب
بفعلته هذه يبدو وكانه يدق المسامير
الاخيره في نعش ترشحه الرئاسه عام 2024
فهو ببساطه يعلن هجوما علنيا على
الديمقراطيه المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
اندروبيت شدد في بيانيه على اهميه دستور
الولايات المتحده وقال انه هو ثقه مقدسه
تكفى او فالمنذ 200 عام الحريه وسياده
القانون في بلدنا الجميله واضاف ان مهاجمه
الدستور وكل ما يمثله مناقد لروحه لروحي
بلادنا ويجب ادانتها وتابع لا يمكنك ان
تحب امريكا فقط عندما تفوز زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ تشاك شومر
ابدا اسياؤه ايضا من ترامب الذي طورت
الاسبوع الماضي في مادبه عشاء مع معادينا
للساميه حضرها نيك فويس
الذي ينكر الهولوكوست ومغني كاني واستا
والان يدعو الى انهاء الديمقراطيه
الدستوريه في امريكا على حد تعبير كما
ادانا جنب ملتن مستشار الامن القومي
السابق ترامب واوضح انه يجب على الجميع
جميع المحافظين على الحقيقين معارضته همم
في انتخابات عام 2024 وانا قلت نيويورك
تايمز عن النائب لجمهوريه المنتخب مايكلر
ايمانه بانه الدستور وضع لحمايه الشعب
الامريكي لكن جمهوريين حرين التزموا الصمت
ومن بينهم كفن مقارتي زعيم الاقليه
لجمهوريه في مجلس النواب الذي يعمل في ان
يصبح رئيسا للمجلس بعد حصولبه على
الاغلبيه
همم
انه غير قانوني ليس هناك سابقه مثلها في
التاريخ الامريكي لقد صدمت لانهما يزال
شخصيه محترمه ويدعمه العديد من الجمهوريين
ولذلك فان كل ما يقوله لا يهم على الاطلاق
لا اعتقد ان ما قاله صحيحا الناس صوت هو
الرئيس الصحيح في منصبه الان وترامب كان
خطا
فادحين
اذا ابتعدنا عن شيء يعد جوهرا للولايات
المتحده سنتخلى عن هويتنا كعب لذلك اعتقد
ان ترامب يحاول ان يدافع عن جدته الخاصه
وهذا هو الحل دائما يمكن ان نرى من خلال
كل الايام المجنونه لاداراته ان ما يهمه
هو اجندته فقط
ضياء من عندك كيف يتابعها الليبيون
يعني ربما ليس مقدر لنا ان نعرف
يعني كيف يتابع
نعتذر مشاهدينا نتابع
بتصريح اليوم اذا
رفضنا عرضا من مشغلي القطرات لزياده
الاجور بنسبه 4% في العامين الحالي
والقادم التصريحها لنقابه البريطانيه
للسكك الحديديه والنقل البحري والبري هذا
الرفض قد يزيد ويضعف الازمه بعد ان عرق لا
اضرابات النقابه بالفعل صفراء الملايين من
مستخدم القطارات اذا الاعياد الميلاد في
بريطانيا هذا العامه قد تكون غريبه وكئيبه
في افضل الاحوال ستجتمع الاسر الصغيره اما
العائلات فقط تنتظر عاما اخر
حديث نجيب ميقاتي رئيس حكومه تصريف
الاعمال اللبنانيه في الجلسه الاولى نستمع
اليها
في اليوم
الماضي
بمقاطعه تسعه وزراء بينهم سبعه من التيار
الوطني الحر اصر ميقاتي على الجلسه
المعنيه بالملف الطبي كي لا يصبح مشاركا
في جريمه قتل المراه
المودعون يطالبونه بان لا يشارك ايضا في
جريمه حزب اموالهم والعاطلون يريدونه الا
يشارك في جريمه تعطيل ارزاقهم والقائمه
تطول وتطولها
[موسيقى]
اما صوره اليوم ففيها بعض من التفاؤل مع
حقول دوار الشمس
نكتفي بهذا القدر من ملفات اليوم في
العربيه 360 وننتقل الى زميل صهيب واخبار
الساعه مساء الخير سهيل
الذي يغطي على كل اخبار ربما هذه الليله
البرازيل انها سددت يعني اربعه اهداف حتى
الان على كوريا
خادم ربما تتشاهد سته اهداف او سبعه
البرازيل هي في قمه السعاده هذه الليله
وعلى راسهم ليليان همم
وانت كذلك ارجنتينيه صحيح
صحيح تفضل